[Music]
okay they're coming in here we go yep
yeah I don't know what the hell happened
there it's a mystery the line
fell lost our connection yeah I don't
know what it was yeah it lost an entire
connection cuz I I lost the Wi-Fi for a
second I don't know I don't know what's
going on said the second time be a child
I don't know well we'll see was it we
got 40 minutes in and then just it just
died
mhm what are you going to do uh hey D
the bomb what's going on get some more
ice yeah here we are we're back just
took me a while cuz it's like well I
didn't know if it was going to come back
on so I said well I'm going to go to the
bathroom and like fix another drink and
then I came back and I was like nope
it's it's still gone so I was like okay
well I guess I got to start another one
yeah I don't know what the hell it is we
don't usually have
um it does it doesn't we don't usually
have problems but you know what I mean
every now and then it kind of shits the
bed and this is one of those times this
is one of those times so all right what
were you you were talking about the
Omega Man probably yeah people back in
well we got some yeah there's some back
in yeah it was just uh
uh at that at that time in that year
black nationalism was big so they wanted
to have a uh they wanted to have a black
nationalist character and they thought
well Neville's a white military man um
so we need somebody that's like opposite
so they made her a
black female black panther yeah and U
you know they they're they they were
cool you know they're friends it's just
uh you know because the world was over
basically as they knew it
so
um it it's a good story she ends up
turning and becoming part of the family
because she was infected but they cured
her later on but it it's good spoiler
alert I mean it's an old movie well they
don't show her being cured but you
assume she got cured zanta said was she
hot though yeah yeah well yeah they're
not going to put a woman in a movie like
that and have her not be hot that's just
not how she had a perfectly round afro
she had cool hair yeah I lik her I liked
her outfits in it too yeah she's dressed
in cool 70s
outfits um pulled a gun on him she
pulled a [__] cult I don't blame her
pulled a Colt 03 pocket hammerless 32
Auto on
him just you get on that bike you you
cool it you she said you cool it it's
like all right that was some 70s lingo
cool it you cool it turkey yeah she made
him didn't say that she made him take
her out of the damn uh
out of out of the damn Arena because the
the the mutants took him into Arena
where they were going to burn him at the
state but they escaped as he do yeah
it's pretty
good hey it's you you know like he'd
seen her
before yes says she can't pick and
choose when the world's ending yeah
right well I don't want to spoil it you
other people there were other
people they had a uh yeah they weren't
the the only on yeah there were actually
she was part of a whole party of people
he just didn't know about it she was
part of a whole party of people most of
them were
children um and uh the guy who was kind
of in charge of children was a young guy
in his 20s who hadn't graduated from
college yet but he was into like
biochemistry and he knew about what was
going on with the
bioweapons and he was trying to cure
these kids but he was a he was a biker
he had a [__] Chopper
[__] brown leather jacket and he was
doing stuff too he was riding around
throwing bombs and [__] at the uh at the
mutants it was kind of like they were
trying to bring together like the man
with like the counterculture like he the
world ended so you know it's all right
y'all can get a lot yeah in the 70s it
was more re more relevant social that
you know that the man and then people
who were like not with the man Charlton
H was representing the man right big
time yeah he was like establishment
right and then they were like The
Counter Culture people right nowadays
the younger people wouldn't [__]
probably get that well there's a lot you
know I don't know I I don't know if I
want to say because I I do kind of feel
like we've talked about this before with
movies and music and stuff where
sometimes it
doesn't hit the same if you didn't live
through the context that they're talking
about like you can appreciate it and you
can like intellectually like know oh
this and that was going on at this time
period but if you lived through it I
think it's different yeah you know what
I mean but Hest man I'm going to call
him the Hest the H yeah the Hest was at
the beest of Hest yeah I got I got a
certain admiration for the Hest he was
kind of
a establishment kind of figure just as a
dude you know and he did play those kind
of roles and he was a very traditional
kind of guy he was kind of like a man's
man of the 60s and the 70s m
ma yeah but kind of like he was kind of
a throwback really even in those days he
was kind of a throwback to like like the
50s he was the cooler version of the 50s
yeah um and
uh he's
he's I mean some people have a hard time
seeing H you know not think of Moses
because he played Moses in the [__]
in the what it the greatest story ever
told I think is what they I thought it
was the Ten Commandments Ten
Commandments that's the Ten Commandments
that's right which is another great
flick if you never seen the Ten
Commandments that's the old school
Hollywood we should probably review that
one although was that movie like five
hours long or something no it's not that
long okay it's not that long yeah it had
I thought I remembered it being really
long yeah and it it had it had that uh
[__] badass [__] from from uh
from Westworld the bald guy what was his
name brener du brener is in it yeah he
plays Pharaoh that dude's kind of sexy
yeah you [__] brener was the [__] man
I always thought he was pretty sex he
was the [__] until he died died of lung
cancer smoking all them cigarettes yeah
he even did and the creepy thing do you
remember this they made him do like
anti-smoking ads and they aired them
after he died yeah so it was almost like
he was on there being like please don't
smoke like after he was dead and I'm
like dude that was pretty creepy brener
was a brener was the original
Terminator from Westworld yeah yeah in
Westworld he played a robot that was
going berserk is a robot gunfighter and
was running around killing the [__]
guest at the Amusement par and uh a a
lot of the ideas of Terminator was
ripped off I mean came from that yeah
came from Westworld the original W
Westworld because I know they remade it
yeah and brener do a [__] great job
in that and he mostly doesn't say
anything there's just his visual acting
his face and then there showing what the
robot sees as he sees you know [__]
kind of like infrared and it's real good
cuz remember we reviewed those sequel to
that too
yeah
uh but Hest was uh a man of his time and
an actor of his time uh he kind of had a
he was kind of stiff in a way but there
was kind of a kind of stiff and uh
uptightness to him in a certain way but
he he he had a cool side to him the I
would say he was kind of like a
prototype Arnold Schwarzenegger he
played a lot of the roles Arnold
would have been cast in had he been back
in those days the thing was about about
H he had a [__] badass face he'd take
his shirt off though and they take his
shirt off in the [__] movies and he
was just bones really he didn't have any
muscle on him really he was big he was
like probably 6'2 but he just bony
really and uh he you could get away with
that back then you could get away with
it back then he didn't have to be like
all or anything he in in the movies he's
throwing a weigh around like he weighs
300 lb of pure
muscle but you know [__] arold would
[__] fold him up like a [__] cheap
card table he probably you
know well I I kind of feel like cuz um Z
said what's your thoughts on Charles
Bronson Bronson was the [__] I always
kind of like I always rather liked
Charles Bronson um and I think he's a
better actor than a lot of people give
him credit for the thing about it is
that Charles Bronson and um charl hon
and all of those kind of actors of that
ilk I guess not necessarily that
generation because there's a different
kind of actor that was more like um like
that came from more like a stage acting
kind of tradition yeah but when you had
these guys that were known for their
like manly man roles that were like in
westerns or action movies or something
like that and their whole thing was to
like play these very stoic yeah manly
man type characters it's like you know
my wife got raped and I'm going to go
get revenge and all this other kind of
stuff and I get the feel like a lot of
those actors were they didn't have a lot
of range I feel no they were playing the
same role over and over they were pretty
much playing the same role over and over
but I do think that Charles Bronson had
more range than than that than that
would um you know suggest what what
Jenny didn't mention about Bronson
though is that Bronson was mostly known
for his later roles when he was older
yeah he in a tonish [__]
yeah and he's not real his physicality
he's not real
physical his rep was built on what he
looked like when he was
young and [__] when he was young he
was [__] shredded he was probably
about an inch taller than me wasn't a
big guy but he probably weighed about
another 5 10 pounds than I did he than I
do he was [__] shredded and he had a
real good Vaper he worked out he was
very physical he yeah he was in real
good shape like when he was younger
Bronson could [__] you up all right when
he was I would not [__] with that dude
when he was in his prime and he had a
badass wife back in the [__] 60s and
70s he and her walk down the [__]
Street in these [__] funky outfits
and [__] with her [__] midrift show I
it was so great like there's old
pictures of that walking down just walk
around in public and [__]
[__] [__] Bronson's arms were
[__] bigger than mine bigger than
mine he was he wasck he was a big dude
yeah he was Jack so so when you think of
Bronson you see a Charles Bronson movie
you're like eh well like for the ones
from like the late 70s and ' 80s like
yeah he's older then but he was in [__]
like going way back my favorite Bronson
movie there's two of them but my
favorite one was called Red Sun and
Charles Bronson plays a a train robber
who's left a gang of train
robbers and he falls in with a Japanese
Samurai to retrieve the emperor's sword
that got stolen during the damn Train
Robbery and he's [__] looking good in
that too and he's 40s and he's [__]
shredded and he's playing playing with a
real famous Japanese actor that was in t
Torah Torah that's a great flick too you
haven't seen that you want to see Red
Sun and it's a rare I saw that in school
you could probably see Red
Sun um s u n okay Sun you could probably
see Red Sun fre free on YouTube it used
to be free on YouTube without with
without any ads um it's from like I
don't know 1970s 71 72 around that time
you can look it up I think 10 to
midnight might be my favorite of his but
um I don't know I'd have to go back and
look then there was another one that he
played an assassin with what was it Jan
Michael vinp yeah yeah yeah and uh we
reviewed that one we reviewed that movie
that was a good was called professional
no no no um what the [__] was the name
of that oh [__] we just did it may a
couple months ago God my brain they kind
of cut out they cut out from the movie
that the two dudes the two assassins
were gay but that was originally in the
story it was yeah and it makes a lot
more story makes a lot more sense when
you understand CU I kind of got that
vibe from the movie too if you could get
the vibe from the movie and then I was
just kind of like in the original story
like were these two supposed to be
lovers cuz I'm kind of getting that Vibe
um but yeah that's we found out cuz like
I said I think when we reviewed that we
talked about yeah that they were like
brutal Psychopathic homosexual assassins
kind of like the cray Brothers yeah and
they were like uh well well they weren't
having sex with each other well no
because they were brothers that would be
weird what was his name [__] the dude
was [__] tying up the little boys to
the bo to the board oh Dean Coral Dean
Coral kind of like that [__] they were
[__] sick how can I just bring then
eventually they turned on each other
they started to turn on each other to
kill each other but they were making a
[__] ton of money [__] killing people
for different organized crime outfits
and they were more and more getting more
and more creative with it I just forgot
the name of that movie I'll think of it
like in a minute because we just
reviewed it like literally like a few a
few months ago that's a good one yeah
Zan is asking what ethnicity he was and
Tammy said uh Lithuanian he's Lithuanian
yeah he European yeah Charles binsky was
his real name yeah ethnic ethnic Russian
from Lithuania yeah part of the Russian
Empire at time now the greatest Southern
Action Hero of all times was [__]
Bert Reynolds all right and and [__]
Bert Reynolds was in a bunch of white
exploitation movies yeah they were made
by the south or exploitation is what
they would call that they were made by
the south for the South there was a
there was a a southern movie studio that
was out of I think Nashville and um it
wasn't Hollywood but they they did very
well I think smoking the Bandit was one
of the movies from that studio the
mechanic that was the name of that movie
The Mechanic that's right very good
movie like I said we just reviewed it
like a couple months ago I just going to
remember you want to see white lightning
all right that was a [__] real good
one with Bert Reynolds him getting out
of prison to help the police figure out
who killed his brother all right to
break a
[__] an organized crime ring I think
it might be Mississippi or Alabama uh
but it's it's the South I remember as a
child and they got it right it's got
white lightning I kind watch it for free
on YouTube I grew up in in Florida so I
kind of feel like we were legally
obligated to like watch Bert Reynolds
movies because I saw a bunch of them
when I was growing up whether I wanted
to or not yeah and they were always on
there's a sequel to White Lightning
called Gator yeah we we've reviewed both
of them it's pretty good we were
reviewed them both we went off on kind
of a Bert Reynolds CH for a little while
we did we did we did best little wh
house in Texas with Dolly part which is
also super fun dolly was hot as [__] man
it's a musical go look at Dolly she's
still do she's still hot still hot she's
got to be 90 she's hot yeah and she's
just seems like a delightful person yeah
she seems delightful then U please don't
tell me otherwi there was another there
was another Bert Ral movies that we saw
we liked it was remember it was taking
place in the
80s and he was a cop in Atlanta remember
he had the black partner yeah yeah who
was having the psychic episodes and [__]
yeah that's right what the [__] was the
name of that [__] that was a good movie
it had I think it didn't have Jee
Simmons in it as a b as the uh no no
that was runaway that was the Tom c one
yeah it there was we've seen so the
villain in it kind of reminded me of
Jean Simmons yeah I see what but I don't
remember I don't remember what the name
of that movie said shy machine shy
machine [__] right Sharky's Machine
that was like one I think we can't
remember that was one of B reynolds's
best movies Sharky's Machine yeah [__]
was
good but uh no I endorsed Reynolds Bert
Reynolds was the [__] man back in the
day forgotten now not really CU he was
in Boogie Nights true true that was like
his that was his comeback that was his
comeback and he was [__] great in
that what a [__] great movie that is
I love that [__] movie I saw that in
the theater when it came out and I've
seen it multiple times since then
smoking the Bandit I never get sick of
that smoky in the Bandit and the sequel
was just kind of a movie you could get
drunk to and get high I saw smoky in the
Bandit yeah so many times it was on HBO
and Cinemax like every day and you know
I was a kid you know I was probably 10
11 something like that and you know you
get home from school you turn on to
cable oh Smoky and abandon on or The
Cannonball Run is on again you just kind
of sit there and watch it and have a
snack nothing else to do no internet
another good Bert Reynolds flick was he
uh was a playing A government assassin
who who said [__] it he walked away from
the job he didn't want anything to do it
anymore he go moves out in the middle of
nowhere in this little bitty town where
this teenage girl falls in love with him
uh but the bad guys track him down there
and he's got to fight them all in the
[__] town it was called Malone that
was a good one too that was pretty good
like I said we went off on a whole B
like several months ago it's just a
lowbudget action flick and it's very
simple and it was good BT Reynolds did a
good job I love that kind of [__] that
kind of [__] it was just a movie you
just watch and just enjoy it you don't
think too much about it you know but
there were some good action scenes in it
but um underappreciated [__] that was
a he's he was a southern [__] Action
Hero Legend yeah I mean he was huge back
in the day yeah and like I said he got
like a real big like um resear J like
when Boogie Nights came out because he
was he might have even got an Oscar nom
for that I feel like he maybe did Bert
Reynolds was the guy that like my dad
would have [__] dug you know what I'm
talking about it was always like it was
like our parents generation yeah my dad
was yeah that's how we ended up watching
it cuz like I said you know my dad's I
don't know if I'd call my dad a redneck
redneck but kind of yeah so yeah we it
was all like Bert Reynolds movies and
NASCAR and all that kind of stuff like
in our house growing up Dukes of Hazard
you know so it was all that kind of
stuff it's you know it's
Florida um Kenny says hi Jenny and Tom
just finished listening to your Jeffrey
Epstein live stream so much information
I never heard before oh that's good I'm
so yeah I Tred to like do a deep dive on
it I didn't like reveal anything that
wasn't out there you know what I mean
but you know I did kind of try to put it
in some kind of interesting you know
when there's so much information out
there about something it's like I try to
cover it all but I tend to stick to
stuff that I think is like really
interesting or what's going to be most
interesting to you guys I feel like
Tammy said that um Charles Bronson was
one of 15
kids whenever I hear something like that
holy crap cuz look like my grandma my
maternal grandma she had eight kids my
mom had seven siblings and even that I
was just like just hearing that makes me
TI I don't even understand like how you
would
even do that you know what I mean like
we have three cats and that makes me
tired I can't even imagine having like
more than one child
so kudos to all the people that have
more than that eight children 15
children I can't even imagine uh Joseph
says I remember Charles Bronson in an
episode of The Twilight Zone with
Elizabeth Bewitched Montgomery that's
Tom's girlfriend there yeah well see one
of my favorite things things about
watching like Boris Carlo's Thriller and
old Twilight Zone and old Outer Limits
and stuff you see the same actors like
turning up like character actors and a
lot of times you're just kind of like oh
hey I know that actor from like a later
movie and it's like here they are when
they're young and that's so [__] cool
like seeing them turn up in Charles
Bronson and Elizabeth Montgomery they
did a thing it was a post-apocalyptic
story remember he was playing like a
Soviet Soldier
Survivor in
and it's like the nuclear war was over
and it was they were enemies but they
end end up I think becoming lovers don't
they well I mean it's Elizabeth
Montgomery yeah so yeah it was a good
flip anybody that meets her Eliz
Montgomery come on man I would hit damn
actually the from that era Elizabeth
Montgomery and uh [__] Barbara Eden
it's hard to beat Barbara that girl was
[__] cute man super cute they were
they were beautiful yeah I mean you know
and they were the competition for each
other Bewitched and and I dream and
Genie were competitors and they know we
got to [__] beat Barbara Eden and
[__] the other network came up with
[__] Elizabeth Montgomery they which
is a great answer as a great response to
Barbara Eden those are both very
beautiful women of the 60s [__]
gorgeous I mean yeah and and I'm not
saying that um but me I'm like more into
like mortia Carol Carolyn Jones yeah and
um Barbara steel I don't remember which
one that was oh she was in a lot of
Italian movies she's British but she was
in a lot of movies she was in like black
Sunday the Mario Baba movies and stuff
like that oh she's hot as [__] and she
was in some uh David kber movies too
yeah she was in Shivers remember she was
the one that had the um that had the
parasite thing go up her cooch in the
bathroom yeah yeah I love Barbara the
thing with Barbara's Barbara Eden was
about the body okay she had a [__]
kill her body especially for the 60s
that was and you know you had always had
good-looking women I mean they had there
are pictures of [__] just knockout
strippers from the 50s mean it's an
embarrassment of riches
really Bell star and some of them old
from the 50s I had some old uh I have a
DVD with like some old um footage of her
yeah like one of those old like 50s
erotica things with Betty pagee and
stuff on it yeah I have I have a couple
of those they they had strippers from
the 50s that were just and and no
silicone they were just genetically
gifted they [__] look great um
nowadays the industry has too much
demand there has to be more people so
[__] uh implants is the way to go now
you know just bump it up that way only
certain girls were born lucky enough
sure but like I said I kind of I'm
willing to take people if they're if
they got their own like thing going on I
can appreciate their own thing going on
they don't necessarily I know I know
you're all about the titties and
everything but that was the world of
stripping sure
it's like it's implants are good no
implants are good it's you know what I
mean it's it's fine whatever whatever
your kind of thing is I'm I'm gonna be a
lot of those girls ended up in Russ
Myers movies like what's her name
Santana Santana what was her name the
the um something or other Santana she
was the girl from faster [__] oh oh Zoe
salana Sal salana that's right not
Santana that's the saltana that's right
she was like a she was a Japanese girl I
believe with with [__]
just very well endowed I don't know if
she was full blooded Japanese but was
she do you remember she was Japanese I
don't know I'd have to look it up like I
think she might have been half Japanese
I really need to read you that Russ
Meyer yeah book you would love that me
and Russ would get along real well we
had a I have a biography of Russ yeah we
we me and Russ and a lot of other guys
like boobs now the thing is is that that
[__] even back in the 50s was a stripper
only thing if you showed that on
television they thought that that was
hypersexuality and that it was it was
rude and gross man they were born that
way you can't blame that woman for
looking like that dudes liked it put
them in the [__] movies and Russ
Myers had it right no we're going to
show it this is the this is the way
these women are built like no we're just
going to put that we're going to show it
and [__] like hell yeah taking
advantage yeah show this [__] that's the
way they looked you know I mean you
know you're going to say that we can't
put you in the movies because your boobs
are too big like it's a disability
disability
no no what are you talking
about well like I said it's not as bad
as it was like cuz um girls with
naturally big boobs yeah um it's kind of
it's like I said it's better than it
used to be but like back in the day if
you had real big boobs people were going
to think you were a [__] like no matter
what even if you try to like cover them
up even if you try to like it's like
that in Japan today that's what I mean
and it's kind of like that's [__] up
it's like look they're my boobs I can't
help it like I was born like this [__]
because she's born with them big old
boobs she's just a girl got big old
boobs you you're it's your reaction
you're projecting yeah exactly
projecting onto that that's [__] up um
that girl might be a virgin for all you
know that's what I mean there's no way
of knowing there's no way of knowing
like I said if they get like humongous
like beach ball implants then yeah
that's a different thing but you know
that's for porn or for fetish or
whatever just cuz you want that some
girls have boob boob greed which yeah
and that's fine too that's like dud but
I'm just saying
big you know some women are born with
humongous titties and it's not like you
can do and you know some of them are
just kind of like they're sick of the
attentions they're like yeah I'm going
to get the [__] reduced yeah um don't do
it ladies well no I mean you can't blame
them though because it's just kind of
like you can't tell them that Tom don't
do it ladies that's my opinion tell my
opinion is well no one has to listen
leave alone just leave them alone I
mean gifts their gifts and learn to work
with what learn to work with those gifts
I know but I can see how some people
would want to like not not have that you
know what I mean cuz it's like it would
be nice to just like go out and be like
normal without everybody like staring at
you it also be nice to it' also be nice
to run across some chick who's just got
these huge boobs so you got to look at
it from the guy's point of view too yeah
but we look at everything from the guy's
point of view always like nobody cares
about like our point of view do that ja
ass boobs and you're [__] cool and
and yeah you're pretty and [__] yeah
this is it man dream come true that you
know ch- Ching you can get married right
guys well I come from a big boo that's
the only I come from a big boo family
that's the only reason you want to marry
somebody is because they have big boobs
no I just I just be I come from a big
boob family my mom was huge all of her
sisters were huge she had [__] Seven
Sisters might be a weird thing that
you're yeah and now just it's just
genetic it's just genetic in me you know
yeah he got used to seeing big titties
like from when he was a baby that's what
they're supposed to look and it's like
that's what they're supposed to be yeah
when my mom in her prime was built kind
of like Sally Fields when when she was
in her prime short little
waist um hips big old double G cup types
boobs
blonde got pictures of it too around
here somewhere weird Tom no I ain't
lying no I'm just saying you I'm not ly
you've seen pictures of her yeah I know
yeah um Z said I always had a huge crush
on Elizabeth Taylor
yeah I could see that she was actually
gorgeous when she was younger Elizabeth
Taylor oh her yeah and then Joseph says
what about ianda Carlo yes also hot also
hot cute yeah I think people only know
her as L as Lily monster but like she
was in a bunch of [__] before that uh
Howard Hughes dated her yeah she's
beautiful she is beautiful all of those
I I really have a thing for like all of
those kind of actresses from back then
there was something about that look that
they had I really was
into Jeffy art says mortia and Gomez are
what any kinky or non- kinky couple
should aspire to G straight see that's
what I always thought that's what I
always loved about The Adams Family
that's why I think The Adams Family even
like going back to the original cartoon
um or their original comic
strip I think I the thing that I liked
about that was that it would be very
easy to make it so that like the
characters that were weird looking were
actually weird but the cool thing about
The Adams Family was that they were
super weird looking but they were just
kind of like this loving really kind of
normal family and every like all the
normies were the weirdos yeah and it's
like and I really really related to that
I liked that a lot yeah the monsters was
was a response from another
U Network to The Adams Family yeah cuz
The Adams Family was a hit I mean I just
thought that was a genius conceit yeah
and and I love love love that they made
Gomez and mortia like the perfect couple
yeah they didn't fight they got along
really they were super in love with each
other and I was like I always thought
that was so so cool yeah what um I saw
an interview with the people that
were wrote the concepts behind both of
those films both of those
series what it was is in California you
had people moving there from the
interior of of the United States that's
that's how my parents got there in the
60s they were my mother was her family
was from Virginia and my dad my dad's
family was from Mississippi but they
moved to California because of Vietnam
my dad being in the service
and my mother's father being a
contractor in the Aerospace
industry and what the series was was
about you had people people from the
interior of the country moving to
California and there were other people
living next door to them that didn't
come from the interior of the company
they might have come from Mexico or from
other
countries so from the point of view of a
person who come to the interior of the
country they were real weird these
people that were living next door to
you they're not like me they're not like
us but the story were is that no they
are like you they just look weird to you
you're not used to seeing them right so
everything about most people are pretty
similar when you get right down to it so
it was the idea was was to uh kind of
like poke fun at people's prejudices
about people who look different like I
said genius right and that's what the
especially for that time period and
because it was a little bit fantasy
because the Adam family was like clearly
very over the top yeah um you know even
though I'm not going to lie I would
totally live in that house but you know
they could get away with it because it
was kind of like well it's not really
realistic yeah you know what I'm saying
so I think that was like and you know
and and um you know the monsters did
kind of the same thing it's like they
you know the universal monsters
essentially yeah um you know but they
kind of played with the same idea but I
mean The Adams Family kind of got their
first like it was there in the comic
strip and I just loved that concept
because that's kind of how I yeah always
felt to be honest with you like having
grown up in the goth scene from a very
young age from when I was you know like
a pre-teen um normies seemed kind of
[__] up you know what I mean like gos
are some gos are [__] up too I'm not
going to say that not all normies though
[__] like Bill Bill was cool well
yeah like and yeah I'm not saying that
just I'm just saying that generally I
think that people have this misconcept
not so much anymore but I think that
back then people had this misconception
that if you looked gothy or something
like that oh you're into all this weird
[__] and stuff like that you're
different not really I mean most of them
were a lot more well adjusted than a lot
of normal people Tak we're taking
appreciation of a different aspect of
things that you're not but uh when you
look at The Adams Family there's a lot
of giveaways and nobody in The Adams
Family is the same Gomez is Latin his
wife isn't they speak French yeah okay
Wednesday's a cute little girl the the
brother isn't he's kind of a little fat
pug pudy little dude you got to the the
the the
the the the [__] what's his name the
butler is this huge tall skinny dude
who's [__] creepy as [__] like
everybody's love yeah a lot of girls
like that guy he's my favorite so a lot
[__] so everybody in The Adams Family
visually looked
different and uh and Uncle Fester you
got yeah Uncle Fester is this crazy
[__] bald dude who could [__] do
weird
sh things and they're just uh kind of
saying that yeah families you know what
I mean [__] can be mixed you can have
people that are of different ethnic
backgrounds they're still people though
they're still doing normal [__] and they
yeah they do funny [__] but you know
what everybody does funny [__] that's
everybody's got an Uncle Fester
everybody everybody would be weird yeah
if they if it was looked at from some
other perspective that's kind of what
they're trying to get at yeah so I like
that they made The Adams Family and I
mean I know that that was the joke but I
like that they made The Adams Family
like the most normal people on the show
like normal people would show up at the
house and they would flip out and they'd
be like what the [__] is wrong with
these [__] like and that's
exactly what I would do yeah and then
they'd feel sorry for people that they
weird stuff which is kind of how I felt
too cuz I'm just like look if I had some
like weird Normie person like show up at
my house and like come up in my office
and be like oh my God what is all this
like with all the horror movie [__] I
have around there I'd be like what is
your problem so it's just so I kind of
feel like the yeah the whole those two
series were about playing with your idea
of what's normal yeah that's all it is
that's why they were so good and like I
said they could get away with it because
they were slightly fantasy based yeah
they weren't super realistic I think
they were effective though they spoke to
people at the time and and people
understood with the message yeah that
yeah people do things differently it
doesn't really matter yeah it's okay
yeah like like I said most people are
generally the same yeah look at my
bracelet got caught on my yeah thing I'm
trying not to rip it but
um High Desert said Earth a kit was hot
oh hell yeah yes hell yeah yeah uh Zan
said not every guy likes huge boobs I
know Tom won't believe that but I'm one
of them yeah it's people like different
things I know that I'm like I said I'm
more of a I don't know what you did I
didn't do anything that's thing how you
got that on there I didn't all I did was
like just move my hand okay just going
to we're going to have to put a hole in
it probably all all right there it'll be
fine it's not real noticeable I mean
they're just fish nets I'll get another
pair but you know what I mean it look it
didn't even make a hole oh that's
something yeah it's one of the one of
the dangers I don't think it ripped it
that's one of the dangers of go look it
didn't break
it the way was it just seemed to be well
see yeah like I would have just ripped
it off but I was afraid because I'm like
oh my God it's going to make this big
huge hole but it didn't all right it's
one of the dangers like one of the one
of the goth dangers it's almost nine
everything catches on everything good I
know just chill
out um
restant kayen hiin said Carol Kane had
an awesome witchy look back in the 70s
yeah yeah I love her too she's awesome I
always really liked Carol Kane um let me
see I used to like burn it at Peter said
Camp Guai oh yeah I remember her I
remember her she's super funny I always
liked her yeah High Desert said the joke
was the Adams were a functional family
and everyone else around them was
dysfunctional despite them being gothy
and weird yeah and I really liked I
think that
conveyed the message like I said like
maybe more than it would have if you
just be because it was just like funny
but you could relate to you were
supposed to relate to them and like not
all these normies that were showing up
at their house and [__] with their
[__] and I just I don't know I just
really liked that and I thought it was
really clever you know what I mean it
was a really clever way to get that
across and let me
see best looking gal in the monsters was
the niece trying to remember her name oh
yeah yeah yeah um she was the only
normal looking one she was the only
normal looking one that's uh was her
name
Marilyn like that was the character's
name I don't remember what the actress's
name was yeah
Marilyn let's
see Hi Desert said most of my classmates
thought all Goths worshiped Satan
yeah well when I was in school back in
the'80s
um that was a pretty common
misconception yeah pretty common
especially during the whole satanic
Panic era that's when that was cuz
really that lasted in the 90s I feel
yeah even know that wasn't goth kids
that was [__] heavy metal kids and
black metal kids yeah it's like we were
just kind of like man we're just like
we're just like over here reading Byron
P piss off you know what I mean it's
like you know what I mean it was that
kind of [__] we're over here reading
Byron and listening to the Cure yeah
heavy metal crap was doing it just a
[__] with you yeah they didn't really
take it serious you know what I mean
nobody did that's why that whole satanic
Panic thing is so hilarious to me
because all these like old people were
flipping out about it only adults took
that seriously they did and it's like
and it's hard to
overstate how [__] up that was unless
you live through it because they really
did old people at that time really did
think that us young people were doing
that stuff and we just thought it was
hysterical that they thought that and
because we thought it was hysterical
sometimes we'd like lean into it because
they were taking it seriously and we
didn't so I just thought that was like
super funny but it ended up having not
so good consequences though CU some
people actually did get arrested for
[__]
and it was not good like I said we did a
show about satanic Panic actually we did
two shows about satanic Panic did we
talk about the MCM Martin preschool case
though on the second one I can't
remember don't remember cuz that was
like a huge and that is [__] up and
that just goes to show how people's
stupid beliefs can [__] up other
people's lives who had nothing to do
with anything yeah I'm pretty sure we
talked about it but your boobs look
great on camera look at you look at you
Tom can't even like think about anything
regular
because they're just boobs huh it's like
gravitation it's a gravitational it's
like gravitational field they're just
boobs I don't even think about it
because it's like they're always there
it's not like I can take them off or
anything boobs yeah he's he's really
into these boobs I
don't it's like so
funny he just wakes up in the morning
and the first thing he does is like
boo it's
hilarious you do
yeah worship it's worship it's boo boy
worship yeah he loves him you
know um Jeffy har said I feel that even
back then The Adams Family was a
statement on how even being considered
normal can come across as a disingenuous
veneer the Adams were so comfy in their
own skin yeah I think that was another
thing that I liked about it is that they
weren't they were weird but they weren't
like self-conscious about they like they
couldn't even fathom like why anybody
else would think what they were doing
was weird well the normies that were
[__] with them were the bad people
yeah exactly that's what I liked about
they were the good people cuz I was like
that's how I always experienced life
yeah yeah so it's like so I really
related very hard I mean The Adams
Family like the original TV show was
slightly before my time um but I saw
them in
reruns and you know cuz they were on TV
all the time and I really really related
to that and then I like I went back and
got books of the Old um you know comic
strips and stuff like the comic panels
and I'm just kind of amazed that they
put a show like that on TV back then
because it seems a little
subversive just looking back on it for
the time at that time the Hollywood
Hollywood had become basically joined to
the military-industrial complex because
of World War II I've talked about this
before after World War
II psychologist World War II is probably
one of the best [__] highly organized
events that the United States has ever
done that's that's they inducted so many
people into the service they were able
to get a grasp on things like IQ because
they did a lot of IQ testing and they
were trying to figure out who who PE
what human beings are and and how they
work well a lot of Hollywood actually
had been voting for Communists they were
communist parties in the 30s and the 20s
and uh they were getting a lot of screw
from the federal government and people
don't realize how many Communists were
in the federal government that were
legitimized and like that was considered
to be a good thing there were even a
couple communist revolts that happened
in the early 1900s that are kind of
forgotten about or erased from history
because they involveed violence and [__]
lot of that [__] was up north around
factories and
stuff well at the time that the war had
happened the the government the military
industrial complex and the government
basically got taken over by the
military um they had privacy and and the
functions of everything and they went to
Hollywood and they said look if you help
us win this war and do your patriotic
Duty we're not going to come after you
over all this your your links to these
communist parties that we don't really
like um and they said okay yeah fine
we'll do
that so the the Hollywood and
entertainment because it was just radio
and television and movies really well
television later and movies
became joined to the military system and
the government
system after the war they realized they
had a big problem on their hands they
had these guys millions of them that
were Killers all right and they had come
from more of a rural
background and they were kind of afraid
to send them back into to where they
came from out in the middle of the
[__] Woods or the sticks out in
[__] Mississippi somewhere they
figured that was going to be
trouble so through the media they they
were able to basically kind of I don't
want to say dupe but influence these
guys to move to
cities work in car factories and
factories and buy houses in the suburbs
and to get married and to have kids as
soon as possible they were trying to
diffuse all these bombs they had created
but those dudes did in World War II
especially because the
Japanese I'd be scared to be around some
of them dudes of what they were doing to
the Japanese on those islands with some
of the most Savage fighting
ever so they were trying to get these
guys married off and get them into a sub
Suburban lifestyle as quick trying chill
them out what's that they're trying to
chill them out they were trying they had
to chill them out so they were going to
chill them out with
television and uh teach him about the
virtues of living a Suburban life and
having a wife and kids in a nuclear
family family where you go to work every
day and um you you're basically vending
your frustrations out on this Factory to
build products that will help America
survive in the world to you export all
this [__] and you'll be able to buy a
car and you'll be able to buy a house
and you'll be able to move up so they're
kind of like in a way bribing these guys
it worked hell yeah it work well well
these series like The Adams Family and
fathers knows better
and all this [__] was
about
deprogramming uh these World War II
veterans and trying to civilize people
those dudes [__] weren't civilized
not as you would know it
today they drank a lot they were prone
to
violence uh because they had
PTSD yeah you know and they didn't
really talk about it no they back then
they weren't sure what that was they
noticed that t those tendencies and
those and they were very diff difficult
difficult to control I've always said
that it's very very
harmful um for societies that encourage
men to not express their emotions in a
healthy way that is going to blow up in
your face well that just wasn't in the
culture that's what I'm saying and um
weakness was not a
virtue but see I don't see that as
weakness like I and I think that's yeah
that's what I'm saying that's kind of
one of the harmful things is like seeing
Express expressing emotion or you know
fear or vulnerability as weakness I
think that's really harmful my Uncle
Buddy was one of them up that's going to
blow up in your face eventually my uncle
buddy I don't know exactly how he was
related to me it was on the southern
side I think that might have been my
grandmother's cousin or something and um
he was an island fighter and I can only
remember him as a child child you I when
I was a child I remembered him and I
remembered liking him he was just this
big gregarious guy and I can remember
him drinking right out of a [__]
bottle yeah a lot of dudes back then it
was very common in that generation very
he was a big Fred Flintstone type dude
from my point of view as a as as a
little
kid he was dead by 40 drank himself to
death that happened a lot yeah he drank
a I mean they went through some [__] I
get it but I don't think it was great
that when you come back there's like a
culture that says you can't talk about
it you can't get upset about it you
can't you know you can't go to therapy
you can't do anything like that CU
that's like that's for girls you know or
whatever that's like a sign of weakness
and I think that end ended up like
[__] them in the
end just they were just Ultra Macho yeah
and
uh any problems they had they just
drowned them with [__] alcohol yeah
which like I said super not healthy not
healthy yeah they didn't talk he was
everything was real positive but he he
had something going on there's no
telling what he did out on those islands
or how much how much death that's what I
mean they kept it all yeah yeah to them
themselves but it was just like eating
them alive like from inside he drank a
fifth of I remember my dad told me when
I got older that he drank a fifth of
Scotch whiskey a day minimum Jesus
Christ yeah I can't imagine yeah so he
was dead by
1980 so late 70s it's a sh it's just a
shame so he might have been in his late
30s actually when he died that's [__]
up [__] up
yeah Ira says I feel like The Adams
Family shows that it's okay to be
comfortable in your own skin and it's
and to be different there's bound to be
people people people similar to you who
become friends or like family that's
what I always kind of liked about that
show like I said that they just showed
these like complete weirdos as regular
people which they are which like I said
I think was like really ahead of it well
that's a message you can take from it
because it's multi-directional and each
little each little episode had its own
little
lesson but the guys that made it the
people that made it wanted it they're
trying to diffuse these people coming
back from the war that's part of the
thing that yeah you've moved into this
suburb and people aren't like you but
that's okay yeah because they came from
a very regimented
background in the military or when there
were kids out in the middle of the
[__] boonies
where everybody they saw was exactly
like them so they didn't have Mexicans
living next door they didn't have gay
people over across the street you know
they didn't have that kind so they had
to they had to [__] somehow break
people to chill them out to break down
the idea that you not everybody is like
you in California yeah especially so
calm town a lot of that [__] even though
it was Nationwide was more targeted
towards California it was everybody else
was just listening in they knew that it
would that it was Nationwide and that
everybody body's watching it but it's
just like my myopia is kind of natural
the guys that are writing these stories
live in California and everybody knows
in California they were kind of
bubble and um the stories that they're
writing are actually for their local
area they just happened to do well
outside the country they well all
writers and I am one so I know like you
kind of use your own experience
to you know tell Story I mean you can
only see things from your own
perspective obviously you can try to see
things from other people's perspective
but you
know so I can see where they're coming
from yeah but all
those family based things you know
[__] what was that other one the um
the one that had Marsha and the Brady
The Brady Bunch Brady Bunch Yeahs Brady
Bunch was about later on that was about
divorce yeah they were trying to tell
people that yeah you get divorced and
you can get divorced and you can remarry
and your kids can live in the same house
yeah and it'll turn out and it's okay
that was like a revolutionary idea back
yeah that was kind of a big deal back
then right because it was kind of I feel
like divorce was still kind of frowned
upon yeah and what do you do they
weren't they up until the 60s they
weren't trained by Society of what do
you do after divorce are you just that's
it you're single that's it it's over no
you can Remar you you marry another
person and they Remar other people who
were divorced another one they did that
was real famous uh was uh oh [__] man
just man I just forgot thinking about
it um oh thre's company thre's company
was about two girls and a guy living in
the damn apartment
together but the guy has to pretend that
he's gay because otherwise the landord
would Ki him out right and that would
some people like what the [__] is this
which nowadays no one would care no
nowadays nobody cares but in those days
but back in those days it was kind of a
big the
idea that a guys was living with girls
and they weren't married that was you
couldn't have that and they weren't
sleeping together yeah they were just
roommates they were just roommates yeah
like now like no one cares that happens
all the time but it's like back in the
70s that was like a big deal and there
was a big thing about him having to
pretend to be that was the whole premise
of the show said he had to pretend he
was he was straight but he was
pretending to be gay so no one would
question him living with two girls yeah
so and notle K him out which is so funny
to think about nowadays cuz I'm like
that's a ridiculous premise it doesn't
make any sense nowadays but yeah it did
back then it did back then it did back
then like I remember I remember cuz I
used to watch that show yep you know
what I mean it's just funny to think
about how far we've come since then High
Desert says all my classmates loved
bands like journey and Van Halen that's
how I got into the care yeah I kind of
feel like what happened in when I was in
junior high in High School junior high I
feel like there were too like people who
cared about it like I guess all the
Normie jock type people were into Van
Halen and all this I didn't really care
about them but there were like two
contingents there were the kids that
were into like goth and new wave and
stuff and then there were the kids that
were into metal and there was like a B I
don't know if I want to say a battle but
there was kind of a thing like where
people would pick on each other from
that from those two clicks you know what
I mean so there was that high school was
a little bit better but I did feel like
I still ended up in the group that was
like into goth and punk and Industrial
and stuff and then all of the other
people like the jocks and cheerleader
types would like pick on us all the time
you know what I mean especially the
dudes they got like beat up all the time
espe if you wore eyeliner or something
like that oh forget it you were getting
your ass beat and this is back in the
late '
80s sobody mentioned
elvar the elvar was kind of she was
great um but she was a ripoff act this
was the original me ner Vampira she had
missfitz wrote a song about her yeah she
had a television program where she would
do uh she just introduced me introduced
yeah she was like a horror host yeah
horror host that's right from the thing
is is almost none of her shows survive
they the the recording were all
destroyed
evidentally and this girl here was the
only girl that actually [__] ever
wore a Chelsea back in the 50s which
Super ahead of her time yeah way ahead
of her time ahead of her time yeah look
at that look how [__] awesome that is
yeah Elvis
deder Elvis liked her Elvis liked
vampire stuff Elvis wore [__] that he
saw off of hammer horror films too well
you know there there's there's horor
movies are cool yeah there's mea and
Elvis right
there yeah see
look him with look at he's got like a
devil lock like like [__] like Miss
yeah n was crazy don't get me wrong that
[__] was crazy she is crazy and uh she
was stalk she looks amazing yeah and she
was stalking James Dean she was one
basically the original goth girl and she
was copying mortia Adams yeah but not
the movie not the TV program program
because it wasn't out yet the cartoon
she was yeah the comic the comic strip
is what she was copying cuz the comic
had been around a long time
yeah way ahead of her time I mean that's
go we're all we're all still trying to
look like
that we acknowledge we acknowledge the
predecessors I want to try to find
that profile cuz like I said the look
didn't come from nowhere right you know
what I mean like a lot of people um are
like you know the the Post Punk era like
from late '70s and stuff with suie and
everything like that which yeah cool we
like copy that too but I mean she's kind
of the OG here it is this is this is her
best photo if you ask me I can't see it
with her oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah she kind of with her and
her kind of looks like Andy she looks a
little bit like our friend Andy she
looks a little bit like her friend Andy
there her hair isn't like that but her
face looks like and that was the
50s yeah which is crazy to think about
and she was that way ahead of her time
gorgeous woman way Ahad of her time
never made any money died broke isn't
that sad y but I feel like that always
happens with people that are kind of on
the Vanguard of [__] yeah no one
appreciates it until after until later
yeah after they're dead or after they're
old yeah you know what I mean when they
can't do anything anymore yeah Bella [__]
s she's a
hotti yeah for real yeah I
mean like I said way a [__] ahead of
her time
yeah she was in PL n from outter space
too yeah although she didn't want to be
in it she was she's like I don't want to
talk in it she didn't have any L yeah
that's a great she was kind of
embarrassed about being that's a great
photo of
her sexy chick see I wish I looked that
good bald you got to be she was tall and
she that's what I mean see I'm like kind
of a short Stumpy kind of chick and it's
just like I feel like that won't look
good she was tall and kind of thin with
big boobs and and she wor she was
corseted so her waist was [__] tiny
she had been using corsetry for a long
time she probably had a [__] tall
thin chicks 16inch waist look good yeah
you can do anything pretty much yeah and
it'll look good if you're kind of like
short and Stumpy like me you kind of
have to you can't just wear anything you
have to be real careful about what you
wear and about how you do your hair too
cuz I would love to do my hair like that
it'd be so low maintenance I would love
it but I don't think it would look good
I have a lot of it shaved but I still
have to have hair in the in training I
think if you were to [__] lose maybe
another 15 pounds of fat I know I don't
know though because I'm still real
short so I don't really know if I don't
know I just don't know how it would look
it only looks good if you have
cheekbones and see I don't really have
this I kind of have like a little round
baby face yeah yeah you tend to be round
yeah and I've always I've always had
that the closest thing to Jen far as
famous celebrities go is Amy Lee Jen Jen
favors Amy Lee a lot when you see Amy
and a lot of people have told me that I
look like her when you see from Evan
Essence if you don't know if you see Amy
Lee with her natural hair color which is
red then they they look a lot my natural
hair is also red it's like well it's not
red it's like coppery orangey is my
natural hair color Amy's a ginger yeah
she just doesn't really appear to be a
ginger she dyes her hair black yeah well
I have so did Elvis Elvis's hair was
[__] Brown he dyed that [__] black
Elvis with goth it's just easy to
maintain yeah it's easy to
maintain you know what I mean yeah and
it goes with everything that's what I
kind of like I liked when my hair was
bright red but then I always felt
obligated I was like oh I have all these
other I have these kind of cool outfits
that have other color Accents in them
like blue or green or purple or whatever
and it's like I can't wear it because
it'll flash you know what I mean so if
it's if your hair is just black you can
wear
anything and then just I then I just
have wigs you know what I mean it just
works out good s says she has nice
eyebrows yeah totally painted on well
yeah that's what I do with mine too yeah
cuz [__] man I'm not pluck I don't have
time to [__] pluck my eyebrows come
on I know you always make fun of me for
saying pluck twe you pluck a chicken
yeah he always every time I say pluck my
eyebrows he's like no you tweeze your
eyebrows you pluck a chicken he says
that every single time
okay so tweeze my eyebrows I don't have
time to do that I used to make him do it
when I had actual eyebrows but then I
was like [__] it I'm just going to like
shave them off I'm gonna shave them off
and I'll just draw them on I just draw
them on whenever I want or I'll just
leave them off if I don't it's much
easier much easier uh let's see oh my
God we're so behind on the on the
comments um yeah hi deser said that's
why they pushed the GI bill to keep the
X fighting men busy in college otherwise
it would have been Revolution if they
ended up back in a Depression era
breadline yeah I do kind of feel and you
know like I said it did seem to work um
to some extent
but because particularly at the time
like dudes were not encouraged to
express their emotions or anything like
that I do kind of feel like they went
internal and a lot of them kind
of started drinking a lot or like did
some unhealthy behaviors that ended up
probably not that great but you know
what I
mean and let's see Hugo says my mom
threw my Shout at the Devil vinyl album
out the window like a Frisby disc cuz
the Black Star on the cover uh CU of the
Black Star on the cover she did it twice
holy [__] yeah I didn't have like my one
thing thankfully my parents were cool I
wasn't in black metal like you were yeah
but um like I liked all the metal I was
into like goth and new wave and stuff
but like my parents were pretty chill um
when I started dressing gothi they
didn't say anything bad about it they
were just kind of like oh that's
interesting whatever but they're just
kind of like okay you just do you and I
will always appreciate that because I
didn't have the whole parent thing where
they were just like tearing posters off
your wall or anything they were pretty
chill about it they were just kind of
like well you like it so it's fine I was
listening to like metal and black
metal through like sophomore and junior
year high school actually actually
freshman
too but by the time I was like sop like
a sophomore or something I was secretly
listening to [__] like [__] Banana
Rama yeah we were talking about that
before I had we were listening to like
banana so I list we were listen to
Banana R before the show yeah and and
listen and Tom's like man a lot of dudes
were listening to this on the slide I'm
like I believe I believe it those girls
were [__] cute man and they were cute
and they could sing and I I would hit
each well especially Siobhan she's
obviously was the go one she was
obviously the hottest one yeah but they
were all pretty they all hot they were
all hot though they just look different
they were different from each other but
uh so I but by the time I was uh a
senior man I was [__] deep
into David Bowie Sisters of Mercy goth
music
uh punk rock I liked it by that time I
was listening to punk rock too actually
I was listening to punk rock in um in my
sophomore year I was jamming with Sex
Pistols and the
exploited Minor Threat I think it was
Triple Threat Minor Threat that's what
it they're from DC yeah I love Minor
Threat um been a long time since I've
heard those then there was one fugazi
they're yeah there was who Ian mck there
was another uh one I think they were
called The Toy Dolls oh I know what
you're talking about yeah I think they
were called the toy dolls I remember
them nobody talks about them much
anymore but I kind of remember them yeah
and then um yeah I don't I got to look
that up and see what they still sound
like it's been a long time since I've
heard the toy dolls s Willam there is a
little bit there's a slight amount of
crossover in the goth industrial scene
because we know some people that are
also into that are into goth industrial
but are also into black metal it's not
super common but it's not uncommon you
know what I mean yeah so and everybody's
just kind of like yeah whatever it's
just kind of a thing I never really got
into metal I appreciate some older metal
now that I'm
older Leslie brings up skeletal family
remember them oh my God I [__] love
it we I well I have a bunch of skeletal
family on my phone uh that I play on my
Spotify playlist I saw them yeah in New
York City at the drop dead Festival back
in
N 2008 or 2009 but they had a different
singer though it wasn't an Marie but
they were still good they were still
good like specimen they were good oh my
God specimen or
[__] uh what I'm into aliens xiend I
like aliens XI yeah uh who's the ones
that were like uh cousins to you
two
um oh um virgin prunes virgin prunes
virgin prunes they did baby turns blue
and all those baby turns blue and uh
what's that one what's that other song
called and I liked a lot of the Neo folk
bands you know Death in June and yeah
Tom loves 93 and David toet and all yeah
all that [__] I love that [__] I love
all that stuff and then um I like the
newer versions of all that stuff like
the homaging like [__] death in Rome
they're real good [__] uh if you
don't know they're a modern band yeah
but they do 80s and 90s songs like like
sometimes cheesy ones but some you know
what I mean but they'll do them like
super serious like goth covers and
they're awesome yeah yeah they did like
pump up the jams yeah Love is a
Battlefield Take On Me Careless Whispers
Careless Whispers all all this [__]
yeah they did like all these [__] um
I think they they did Barbie girl yeah
Barbie girl right so did they do the
sign yeah they did the sign yeah so they
did like all songs like that but they
like super got them out and they're
really really good yeah good they're
really good yeah just just covers that's
all they do that's all they do is covers
they're all dressed up in these looking
like German looking outfits like like
the brown shirts and awesome they they
have a whole aesthetic they have a whole
aesthetic yeah but their songs are Death
in June it's the same that's why they're
called Death in June they just call it
death in Rome yeah but they just take
songs that you wouldn't think yeah would
sound like goth songs yeah and they
totally make it sound like a goth song
like if you didn't know that was a
cover you probably would not know you
know what I mean like you would just
think oh that's like a like a goth Tak a
l song and make it a goth sure yeah or
like I said well and I've said this
before I think a lot of like 80s I think
the reason that a lot of Goths were into
80s New Wave even though it's like kind
of poppy is that 80s New Wave A lot of
it had yeah it was like kind of upbeat
and everything like that but it kind of
had a Melancholy to it you could very
easily turn that into a goth song which
like I said they took Take On Me which
is a real upbeat kind of song and they
turned that into like a super like a
durge yeah yeah and it's great it sounds
really really good take on me yeah and
they didn't really have have to change
it all that
much the cool thing the cool thing the
thing that I always loved about 's New
Wave was that they took all of
these horrible depressing
topics and turn them into upbeat pop
songs look at something like 99 Red
Balloons for example uh or 99 lft
Balloons if you like that's the original
one uh the who nah did that is a song
about an accidental nuclear war is what
that is but it's like a super upbeat
look at something like the OMD song anol
gay yeah that's about the bombs dropped
on Japan like the hydrogen bombs I don't
think it'll get us cuz I don't think let
me see if yeah you
might let pump up the jam Pump Up the
Jam
okay it's great I love
it
that's kind of what they do that's what
they
do I love that they change boots for
booty I love that I love
[Laughter]
it fantastic fantastic but yeah that's
what they do they take songs that you
would never think were like goth songs
and they turn them into goth songs and
it totally works it totally works Love
is a Battlefield is my favorite like the
pat benitar song but they're all good I
don't even remember didn't they do
another one just recently that you told
me about I can't remember what it was
didn't they do another one they're doing
all kind yeah they don't release albums
they just release a song at a time on
the just go on and a video just on death
on death in Rome on YouTube and you can
see all their [__] yeah it's great it's
free but they also do they do live shows
too yeah yeah I'd love that [__] well
every now and then like if like if we go
to mannequins for example and the DJ
Paul vain if he sees Tom there he will
play that yeah because yeah if he sees
me he starts playing he'll play that CU
he's like oh Tom's here I'm gonna play
that song I'll be the only one to dance
to it too he usually early well yeah he
plays that kind early if we get there
yeah he sees me he starts playing oh
we'll see how
Okay H let's see yeah we smoke
cloes yeah I haven't for a long time sto
smoking yeah CU we sto smoking if I'm
drunk enough and I'm out and somebody
offers me one I'm not going to say no
but I don'ts I don't buy them anymore
but I do like them D blacks yeah that
was kind of the thing wasn't it you do
kind of see that you don't see it as as
much as you used to if you see anybody
smoking I mean you do occasionally see
people vaping but not as much as you I
mean the last few years I haven't really
seen anybody smoking or vaping no much
it's all just kind of gone other than
some sometimes like you see the older PE
because we know a couple of the older
people like our age that still smoke
yeah um but it's very rare you don't
usually see much of it anymore I'm going
to shut it down in a few minutes yeah we
got to get uh we got to get going like
so behind on the comments though I feel
kind of
bad um yeah Hugo said in the beginning
the monster show had to change the look
of Lily monster because she looked a lot
like
mortia yeah I mean they made her look
more like the Bride of Frankenstein
which totally works but that was I like
the monsters too but I like The Adams
Family a lot better because it was kind
of like I said it was kind of the first
one um yeah vampire alvir let me see
holy crap I'm sorry I got so so behind
but we just got like
distracted hi deser said there's a story
that she put a death curse on James Dean
I have heard that too I don't know if
that's true or not either but I have
heard that also I have heard that
also uh let's
see
yeah oh Blake seven yeah I kind of
remember
that
Zan said I heard Tom say before that
tall girls have the heartest time
getting dates um yeah and from my
experience because I was uh friends in
school with girls that were tall and I'm
talking like over six foot tall and they
had a [__] of a Time [__] of a Time
dudes want don't want to be with
somebody that's taller than them you
know what I
mean
thank you so much Hi Desert have some
cloves on me I haven't bought any cloes
in so
long like I said they do sound good
usually if I'm out and I'm kind of like
drinking and dancing and stuff it's like
if somebody gives because we have a
friend that still smokes and sometimes
she still brings him and she's like hey
you want one I'm just like sure why not
but Tom can't smoke him anymore like he
just starts coughing I haven't smoked
one in a while though I think the last
time I smoked one
was when iar was still downtown which
it's not anymore now it's in the factory
district um Zan said my parents let us
watch almost anything yeah mine did too
they didn't really they weren't really
bothered I mean I they didn't get it
because neither of them were into horror
[__] or anything I kind of in a weird in
a way I kind of
Envy kids growing up nowadays that are
raised by parents like our age or a
little bit younger that are super into
horror movies and they're just like hey
what horror movies can I can my kid
watch and all a sudden and I think
that's so awesome my parents were like
they would let me watch anything they
didn't care but they didn't really get
it they weren't like really into horror
so they were just kind of like oh okay
we don't we don't understand what you're
doing but just do what you do oh got
super chat it was just kind of yeah yeah
yeah yeah that's super awesome he yeah
he said have some cloves on me okay
thank
you can you even get those anymore yeah
you can you can get them yeah you can
give the next door to [__] mannequins
they have oh that's right oh I forgot
that they have that little shop is yeah
I forgot yeah hi deser said now I'm
feeling zombified oh my God yeah aliens
X fend yo yeah aliens xend I love aliens
X Fiend I love Alien Sex be um let's
see I guess oh High Desert said uh swans
did a great cover of level terce part
yes they did um I [__] love the swans
um probably I'm trying to think what my
best what my favorite album is of theirs
that was the that was the band that we
saw that you that freak that you freaked
the [__] out that somebody dosed me with
something yeah so that was like a bad
night but I was like super excited to
see them cuz I never got to see them
before and you kind of ruined it but it
wasn't your fault though but um but yeah
I'm just kind of like maybe
uh I want to say maybe cop is my
favorite or greed I can't really
remember but yeah I really really like
the spawns a lot like I said I saw them
live but it was kind of uh inexperience
and high desert says current 93 is a is
an homage to yeah theim alisher KY yeah
yeah they're all into that kind of [__]
yeah I think we DAV tet was all in
there's a good they had a good project
album between David
Tibet and Douglas Pierce from Death in
June it was called nature and
organization where that's a really good
album I think that's the name of the
album and the band nature You Can Get It
Free on
YouTube yeah that's I like all that all
that that's good all that it's all this
[__] friederick nii meets [__] uh
Arthur scoph Hower yeah Germanic
Buddhism they're all into it's all about
yeah yeah all that [__] is great I love
all that all right so we got to wrap it
up because we're going out and it's 9:30
so it's about a 20 minute drive down
there so um Zan said we let my brother's
seven-year-old son watch The Shining he
loved it yeah totally understood it yeah
okay that's awesome though because I
love when movies that are that old cuz
[__] man that came out in
1980 and I love when people that weren't
even alive when that was made like go
back and watch that and they just
totally get into it when that movie came
out old people didn't like it they
didn't understand it yeah that was one
of those movies that got like kind of
well I don't know if yeah it it got kind
of [__] reviews it got good reviews too
but it kind of got [__] reviews at the
time too which blows my mind cuz that's
like one of the best horror movies ever
duh obviously um but the same thing
happened with the thing you know what I
mean people were D back then they didn't
know any better yeah they said the thing
sucked no the thing was [__] awesome
man yeah what are you talking about and
like and I feel like everybody knows
that it's awesome now so Jesus Christ
people were dumb back then they didn't
know any better all right so we're going
to go uh get ready and head out for the
evening so hopefully you guys have a
good weekend like I said we got to drive
to oal tomorrow too so we'll see how
that goes I might do another review on
Sunday I might not cuz I might not have
time to like watch anything if not then
we'll be back on Monday night doing
either Inception or The Departed which
other one we feel whichever one we feel
in the mood for watching so hopefully
you guys can drop by for that thank you
for hanging out with us this Friday
evening thank you for the super chats
and we will see you again probably on
Monday night good night